Shane Gillis already has a new roommate
after moving into his home in Austin
Texas a few short months ago you going
have a talk we're going to have a talk
also we have a talk about the duration
of this living arrang cuz there's no way
you're leaving there's no way you're the
way this ends is be going you got to
get get out of here dude I didn't really
ask about a duration and the other day I
asked and he was like I don't know
probably like April I was like God damn
ite it's like six months dude it's so
long yeah the six Le it's crazy Lam mer
Lee was previously living in Matt
mccusker's office space for an extended
period of time so for the forseeable
future it looks like